okay I'm using a camera with a very
different lens and I cannot see usually
I have a camera that has like a little
pop-out screen so when I'm sitting in
front of it I can at least see where I
am in the frame and this I cannot I am
blindly trusting technology
what did cavemen do they must have been
riddled with anxiety today I want to
talk to you guys about haters that can
be people that leave negative comments
on YouTube people that treat you
unwarranted ly rudely in a daily life
forum thing that's not web videos what
is real life overall just someone that's
got a lot of negativity about them
that's looking to put someone else down
this is not new this has been happening
forever as long as there was someone
putting himself out there for public
criticism there was someone in the
public criticizing them negatively and
being someone that has made web videos
for years and years I feel like I've
developed a thick skin for harsh
criticism here are five things that you
can do to handle the haters number one
feel bad for them putting other people
down is just a form of projection here's
the definition of projection because I
don't want to say the incorrect thing
and it lists it negative come back it
usually comes from someone that's having
a really bad time inside themselves
wanting someone else to feel that pain
so you can choose to be affected by them
or you can choose to feel bad and then
no one ever told you that you're a
goddamn idiot and anyone wasting their
time watching this [ __ ] is also a
minute yes I am affecting you
no it's a get up shout I'm sorry I can't
hear you over my own warning for your
internal sadness that feeds your
constant need to put others down so that
they somehow feel what you unjustly feel
unjustly on a daily if not
because we're so sad
Oh number to agree if you can't beat
them join them
even if you do not agree with what
they're saying about you because chances
are it is not correct agreeing with a
bully
totally deflates their anger their need
to fight because all they want is a
fight and if you don't give them that
what do they have left
it's literally like watching someone
fight with a pillowcase you're an idiot
yeah big time no like seriously you're
idiot no seriously I know no seriously
you're idiot yes yes oh my god just
fight it Jesus Christ
number three imagine them in a
completely ridiculous way everyone says
when you feel nervous public speaking
imagine the audience in their underwear
but that would make me way more nervous
so instead imagine a bully or hater in a
way that makes you um
whoa you're not funny you try too hard
on your toes sellout you're an idiot
and you what goes Shh what number four
imagine them speaking in Farsi that's it
you're not finding you tried too hard in
your toe ah thank you for your opinion
number five kill them with kindness
you're an idiot you you try too hard
you're not funny
I'm proud of you for speaking your mind
[ __ ] you what I appreciate you no buts
stuck on your opinions and just know
that I think that you're worth something
uh-huh you're killing me with kindness
I'm dying we're all gonna die someday
isn't it sad that you wasted your whole
life being a terrible shame
oh my god I'm going back to number one
there you go
there are five ways that you can handle
the haters I hope that this was helpful
and if it wasn't yeah make sure you like
that I don't know
this don't forget the memory heart and I
are going on a comedy tour of the south
eastern ish part of the United States
links for tickets are down below also
don't forget if you have forgotten and
if you don't know at all that I wrote a
book Grace's guide the art of pretending
be a grown-up
please don't miss the opportunity to
order yours at Grace's guide book com
you're not missing an opportunity words
are just now flooding out of my mouth
don't forget to subscribe this is me
giving like fingers but I said subscribe
cuz I'm wired all over the place today
like the video and subscribe if you want
to it happens human beings are not
always great human beings if you think
about for too long you will get so sad
ah female Taylor Swift's new album we're
back